judicial watch president tom fitton
along with the reuben reports dave rubin
joined me now all right guys we don't
have a lot of time
tom uh you know i love you you get
information
from that congress can't get all the
time because you sue everybody
let's talk about the big tech uh section
230
for some reason they get protected what
what can we do about
their protection the law should be
reformed because the courts are
misinterpreting it to allow them to
engage in
uh bad faith discriminatory activity and
censorship against conservatives
they just locked me out of twitter uh
yesterday
after i posted a tweet that they had
previously found to be not in violation
of their rules it relates to
the hcq drug completely irrelevant and
they tell me i can't go back
on for at least seven days this is a
pretextual way of getting out a leading
conservative
and it's not about just censoring people
for saying the wrong things
they don't want us to be on the internet
everywhere anywhere
so going over the parlor may work for
some time but i guarantee you
uh or i i predict unfortunately that
parlor won't be around in a few weeks
the way things are going it isn't it
isn't
it isn't they suspended it today go
ahead dave take it
yeah judge it's just in the last few
minutes that it's not just apple
it's not just apple and google play that
took them off their stores
now the amazon servers have gone down
for parlor so they're down for about a
week look
we just have to keep fighting you know
you may remember the the red wedding in
game of thrones when they took out about
half the characters
well we're seeing a red wedding of
social media right now they are trying
to take
out every counter voice you know i
started locals.com we build digital
homes for creators i'm i'm pretty sure
you're about to launch on there and greg
gutfeld's on there and scott adams
and a whole bunch of other great people
we're trying to give people tools
so that you can create a type of
internet that's better for you that's
what i'm doing people can check it out
at reubenreport.com but we're not we're
not perfect we're not safe we know the
knives are out for everybody
and i hate to say it but a whole bunch
of us we told you this was coming and if
and if they take out trump the way they
have systematically knocked him off all
of these things
this does not matter what you think
about trump it doesn't matter what you
think about the last couple days on
capitol hill
they're showing you hey we can come for
anybody
and everyone should be standing up and
yeah of course we're seeing the media
cheer it on because they
you know orange man bad yeah
i mean you take responsibility for what
we do
go ahead yeah i mean that that violence
was inexcusable and
but the left has now said if you oppose
their policies that's the equivalent of
violence and you have to be removed
if you raise questions about election
integrity you can't be on the internet
if you raise questions about the
lockdowns you can't be on the internet
so opposing policy is a reason for you
to be removed
by these big tech companies section 230
it never envisioned that taking place it
doesn't allow
for it it doesn't need to be changed it
needs to be enforced
and the ftc needs to go after these
companies for engaging in business fraud
for telling the public they're removing
people for one reason
when in fact they're removing them for
another politics
yeah but i i i hate to tell you guys
democrats controlling the senate and
everything else yeah we're in a lot of
trouble guys like we
everyone needs to start figuring out
off-ramps for the big social media
things right now they're watching this
right now there's no doubt that someone
at facebook and
someone at twitter and the rest of it
are watching these shows they're
figuring out
how can we get everybody else this was
coordinated
we all know it and we're sitting there
going oh can somebody save us
nobody's coming to save us guys like th
this really is it
we can use the mail
we use the us postal service still
that's why because
the internet is not safe for any
conservatives in terms of being
protected from censorship
no matter where you are
so what did you say we use we use the
mail
i mean it may be that we just have to
communicate the old-fashioned way
the u.s postal service i don't know dave
rubin has a good idea
dave reuben has a good idea with loans
anyway gentlemen good to have you both
on
yeah go go ahead
look david beat goliath right like the
the little guy can beat the big guy
these things seem huge they seem all
encompassing
they seem ubiquitous and like we can
never escape them but they will destroy
themselves
and we just need to build some things in
the meantime yeah we hope
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell